In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion for October 1st, on which we commemorate.
The Holy Monk and Chantur, John Cucuceles, who led the ascetic life at the great Lavra
on the Holy Mountain of Athos and died in peace.
Our Holy Father, John, was born at theadachium, now Dures, in Albania, in Ilyria at the end
of the 13th century.
His father died in his childhood, and it was his mother who had him educated by the most
renowned masters.
His angelic voice brought him early recognition.
He became the best of the court singers and the favorite of the emperor, who wanted to arrange
a good marriage for him, but at heart the young man only wanted to take leave of the world
and embrace the monastic life.
God provided an opportunity when the abbot of the great Lavra visited the court.
John introduced himself to the abbot without saying exactly what his court office was.
After testing him for some days, the abbot clothed him in the angelic habit and took him with
him to the Holy Mountain.
He was given the task of taking the goats to graze in the hills.
There, far from every human soul, he spent the entire day in prayer and addressed God
on high in such sweet tones, but the very beasts of his flock looked up from their grazing
to listen, and the whole of nature seemed to grow still as if loath to disturb him.
But, one day, he was heard by a monk, who was so struck by his wonderful gift of song
that he told the abbot about it.
John was then obliged to say exactly who he was.
Meanwhile, the emperor had sent everywhere to look for him.
But, thanks to the abbot's pleas on his behalf, John was allowed to remain on Mount Athos.
He settled near the Lavra in a cell dedicated to the Holy Archangels, where he lived in solitude
for six days of the week, returning to the monastery on Sundays in order to chant in the church,
which lifted up the hearts of many among the monks.
On the fifth Saturday of Great Lent, when we sing the Acathist, he sought to raise his voice
in a worthy manner to the most holy mother of God.
She appeared to him, handed him a gold coin and said,
rejoice, John my son, chant for me, and I will never leave you.
Then the all-holy mother miraculously cured the gangrene that affected his legs through
his standing hour after hour in the choir.
John spent the rest of his life in repentance, fasting, and continuous prayer.
He knew beforehand the day of his death, so he was able to gather together the brethren,
ask their forgiveness, and request them to bury his body in his Kellion of the Holy Archangels.
His musical compositions, many of which survive in manuscript, mark a decisive stage in the
development of Byzantine music.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.